[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
always Alex muellering and I'm excited
to be talking with you today about our
topic there's been some major chess
tournaments going on recently and
something that I get asked every now and
again is you know I'll watch people uh
watching major tournaments and watching
these professional games Grand Masters
going back and forth and they'll it's
really impressive it's really amazing to
watch but people sometimes think well
how am I ever supposed to get to that
level or how am I even supposed to learn
something from those games because it
seems like it's so Advanced and so today
I want to try to answer that question
you know what can I learn from Master
games how can I use those to help
benefit my chess we're going to look at
at least one maybe a few games and kind
of talk through this
but I have a few suggestions right off
the bat I want to give first one is you
can do something called guess the move
which is where you'll go through a game
this is one we went through last week
but you'll go through a game and you'll
get to some position
and you'll think okay if I had the white
player uh the white pieces in this
position what might I do and then you'll
submit okay here's the move I think I
would try and then you see what white
plays played E3 and if your move was the
same well you played a move of
Grandmaster played if your move wasn't
uh then what I like to do is I'll just
check it with the computer and see if
the computer likes my move as well or
less so and maybe look through some
variations to try and figure out why so
that's one very solid way a lot of
people like to do it I think that
usually works a little better at more
advanced stages though because there's
some really complex stuff going on in
Grand Master games and it's easy to get
overwhelmed and just always miss it
especially in positions that are more
complicated and don't lend themselves to
one really good forcing move
so I'm going to do this a little
differently and you might have not done
it this way but I hope you stick with me
but my recommendation is we're going to
go through we're going to start with one
game and see where we go from there
we're going to start with the game this
one was between Vasily Smith and uh
Yosef rudakovsky in 1945 so that's the
master game we're going to be starting
with and the method I'm going to use you
can apply to any game you could do it
with your own chess games even or those
of your friend but I also think it's
going to be effective with Master games
we're going to walk through the full
game you know kind of a brief analysis
trying to at least understand what was
maybe the main point of some of these
moves but we're not going to get too
deep into the analysis or the different
variations I'm just going to try to
understand basically what happened in
the game
if you were playing Guess the move you
would prefer to go much slower and try
and really dig in with your analysis but
here we're not going to do that we're
going to see the answers but at the
before we have to take the test
and then we're going to go back through
we're going to think what were the
moments that stuck out maybe moves that
we didn't understand or stuff we want to
just understand a little better
so let's take a look with this game
in the the beginning vasilis mislav
played E4 and his opponent played C5
this is the Sicilian Defense the basic
ideas right for both sides White's
trying to control the center like normal
probably going to develop some pieces
try and fight for the center
black is trying to fight for the center
as well but instead of doing it the
classical way uh trying to put upon here
in the center as well Black's taken this
flank approach coming at it from the
side but attacking a Center Square
trying to stop light from getting that
control
Knight to F3 controlling D4 adding a
Defender here and E6 kind of an
interesting move not seen as often today
the often the reason you're playing this
move is because you want to add an extra
Defender to the D5 Square so now black
is maybe looking to push this Pawn
forward and it also opens up this bishop
as a defender of the C5 Pawn if that
ever becomes relevant
pull into D4 so white strikes in the
center and black happily obliges and
both sides have some trade-offs here
right we're gonna not get too in depth
with our analysis but the trade-offs are
basically white has great control in the
center this Knight and this Pawn black
doesn't have as much control in the
center but they have traded off one of
their side pawns for one of White's
Center pawns so maybe in the long term
they can use these extra Center pawns to
try and gain a more long-term Advantage
there's a kind of a short-term control
versus long-term strategy going on here
Knight to F6 attacking the pawn on e4
and white plays Knight to C3 developing
defending the pawn
and pawn to D6
so this is uh now the Chevy ningin
variation you don't have to know a lot
about what that means but this is kind
of a trickier line from black a little
more passive but there's some kind of
ideas of preventing two early attacks
from White
white continues with Bishop E2 a natural
developing move doesn't get too
aggressive or out there but looking to
develop the bishop gain some control and
probably Castle the king
and black does the same
and we have castles castles both sides
are mostly developed white has one
Bishop left to get in the game black has
a bishop at night
and let's see how they do it Bishop to
E3 makes sense Knight to C6 putting some
pressure here on the center
and white plays Pawn to F4
looking to put more control on E5 right
this Pawn adds a Defender here The Rook
behind it so maybe looking to open up
some attacks on the king side one day
Queen to C7 so now we can see the fight
is more clearly over E5 right white just
played a move with the pawn attacking it
and Black's queen move defends through
the pawn to help that square so both
sides are trying to gain control here
and white plays Queen to E1
a very subtle move right any kind of the
queen moves you always want to be
watching out really carefully because
they're such versatile pieces in this
case we can pretty easily figure out the
benefit right on the D file it was
defending this Knight which was
important but the bishop is also doing
that
but it really wasn't able to do anything
else it was kind of locked in here on E1
it can't do much but it can exit on this
dark Square diagonal and maybe put some
pressure on the king side so that's
probably what White's looking to do
and here black goes for a trade Knight
takes D4
white recaptures with the bishop
naturally and pawn to E5
striking at the center gaining a little
bit of Tempo by attacking this piece
white backs off and here Bishop to E6 is
played developing the bishop you might
notice there's a question mark there
don't worry about why that's a mistake
we'll get to it in a moment white here
continues with F5 attacking the bishop
gaining some time against it and what is
the bishop going to do it could retreat
but then you might ask well why didn't
it just go to D7 on the first move so
black and said decides to play Bishop to
C4 offering a trade
white decides to accept Bishop takes
Queen takes
and now white to move this queen again
we wanna anytime a queen moves look out
for what it's doing it's putting some
pressure on this Pawn but that's pretty
well defended some pressure on e4 maybe
that's a little more important right the
Knight and the queen both attack only
the Knight defends so white doing wants
to do something to defend this square
and they do it with Bishop to G5 which
attacks the Knight and also opens up the
queen to add an extra Defender to the
pawn
okay black continues Rook to E8 trying
to centralize their Rook and white
captures the Knight okay Bishop takes
back
and Knight to D5 putting the Knight on a
beautiful Square here in the center of
the board where it controls a lot of
space makes a lot of threats
black backs off Bishop to d8 not really
any other good spaces to put it you
could try to maybe put it on G5 here but
maybe it still gets chased away somehow
so black just decides to bring it all
the way back defend a lot of these
squares from this Knight
white plays Pawn to C3
when I first look at this that move
looks maybe a little strange only reason
is well it's not really defended so
maybe White's just looking to keep it
safe defended by some pieces
B5 black maybe now trying to gain space
and strike against the queen side
Pawn to B3 attacking the queen
she doesn't have a lot of places to go
can't take this Pawn because it's still
defended by the Knight and the queen so
the queen goes to C5 with a check and
the King has to go hide
Rook to C8 lining The Rook up with the
queen and putting it on this nice
semi-open file pieces generally like to
be placed where they have the most space
and options and in this case The Rook
the fact that there's no black pawn
anywhere on this row uh in or on this
column in front of the Rook means that
it's going to have more power and more
influence on the square
white plays Rook to F3 thinking
similarly that this Rook wants to be a
little more active than it was back here
behind the F5 pawn and now it's doing
multiple tasks one it's defending this
Pawn from the attack and two it could
also be looking to slide over to one of
these files and put more pressure on the
king yet again
King to h8 getting the king out of
totally out of any diagonals maybe
wanting to push this Pawn one day and
step away from an attack here and just
get a little more to the corner
Pawn to F6 looking to strike forward
break open this King side and try and
launch an attack
black decides to take with the pawn
this seems like an important moment to
come back to what else could black have
done what's going on here but black in
the game chose to take with the pawn
and queen to H4 this is a pretty nasty
move we remember earlier on Queen was
moved to E1 in order to develop to the
king side and now we see it's ready to
strike the queen is putting a direct
pressure against the king lined up with
him and there's lots of threats maybe
threats against F6 threats of moving The
Rook over and getting a Checkmate so
black has to be very careful to survive
here
Rook to G8 with the idea of bringing the
Rook up to G7 to defend this Pawn which
is basically what happens the Knight
takes on F6
and The Rook which was attacked now CO's
here to defend against the Checkmate
threat
Rook to G3 a really nice move by white
looks like they're trying to attack this
rook and lure it away right black can't
just take because our Knight and queen
make a Checkmate threat if that Rook
leaves
to get rid of that black first plays
Bishop takes Knight now you could take
because the knight's not defending
anymore so Queen takes F6
and we notice there's now a little bit
of a problem for black
this Rook is now pinned there's no time
to take because the queen would then
take Black's King
there's also a Checkmate threat right
this rook and queen double attack this
rook and you need an extra Defender so
black shifts the other Rook over Rook to
G8
and white now tries to find a way to end
this game and does so pretty simply and
effectively with Rook to D1
the point here is going to become clear
if you don't see it and one of the
benefits to a Master game and especially
this method is you don't have to see it
because the Masters might play it out
for you
black plays Pawn to D5 kind of desperate
to do anything white trades The Rook
and then actually in this position
black just resigned I believe with the
idea that if they take back the point is
white will play Rook takes D5
and attacks the queen threatens Rook to
d8 check not quite Checkmate because you
can block but there's no good move here
right we can imagine if black just tries
to Save the Queen
then this will be check the Rook can't
block because it's pinned so the queen
will have to jump back and check mate
and even if you bring the queen to
defend this right cover the square you
can still just play Rook to d8
because the queen will have to trade and
it's not quite Checkmate but a queen
versus a rook white should have a fairly
easy time cleaning up this game
okay that didn't take super long right
we maybe about 10 15 minutes something
like that but we got through a whole
Grand Master game and you might say well
that's great but you the teacher were
kind of walking us through it and maybe
you weren't seeing all the ideas I was
explaining and that's okay these things
take time and having a teacher to
explain the ideas is always helpful but
now that we've seen the game even if you
didn't really have all those ideas in
your head we can now go back with kind
of the hindsight of what happened and
take a closer look and try and analyze
what happened what specifically what
were the ideas what worked what didn't
and we can ask ourselves how can I apply
the lessons that happened here to my own
chess so let's see if we can work
together and pick out some really
important moments from this game
my recommendation when we look at the
opening is you want to be kind of
careful right because in an opening
there's a lot of theory and especially
the higher level you get the opening is
more and more just Road mapped out as
opposed to kind of intuitively felt so
there's kind of a danger of looking too
closely at the openings because again
theory is going to take over the things
I think you should focus on are how do
each player do follow the three opening
principles because every opening every
good opening is going to be following
those three what are they controlling
the center so how are both players
placing pieces on or attacking these
four Center squares
how are they developing their pieces
especially the knights and the Bishops
because you need to get those out quick
right if you leave your pieces on the
back row they're not nearly as effective
so how are they developing their pieces
how are they controlling the center and
finally how are they keeping their kings
safe right King safety if you lose the
game it's because of a Checkmate or a
threat of it or you resign because
you're going to get checkmated
eventually the king is the most
important piece in the whole game and so
looking at how both sides handle keeping
their King safe in the opening is going
to be really helpful
so I kind of talked through some of
those ideas as we went but on our second
look round we can see that both sides
are doing something similar right E4
puts a piece on the center attacks the
center square and it indirectly helps
development by opening up lines for
these pieces to emerge should they
choose to do so
C5 again fights for the center in a kind
of indirect way not as helpful with
development it does help the queen get
out and subtly it also helps this night
with development a little bit because
now when the Knight gets into the game
it won't be blocking this Pawn right we
can imagine if E4 or sorry E5 had been
played
something like this this is a fine thing
to play but notice that this Pawn is now
not as easy to get into the game and so
one of the benefits of the Sicilian is
you avoid that problem
now whenever the Knight jumps in it's
not going to be blocking that pawn so
you have a little better control of the
center because of this Pawn
Knight drops into F3 natural developing
move
E6 and again our expectation was
probably D5 we learned later that's not
actually what happened in the game uh
black played Pawn to D6 so a little more
passive but still giving a little bit of
room for the bishop to come into the
game
D4
and it's hard for black to not take this
Pawn if you let whites kind of stabilize
the center stuff gets really hairy
um white could even back this up with C3
and always have these two Pawns in the
center so D5 is possible but I think
taking makes the most sense here
Knight to F6 Again part of this is
opening right it's Theory but we can
still break it down with the principles
this move helps every single principle
it attacks the center of the board
attacks a weak Square it develops a
piece from the back row and it clears
room for the king eventually to Castle
so it's helping in every aspect even if
we don't always think of it in that way
Knight to C3
similarly just defending opening up
space we know white doesn't Queen side
Castle but it's keeping that option
alive potentially and just developing a
piece
D6
Bishop to E2 again we might ask why
didn't this bishop go further and again
this might be a more theoretical
question you could look with computers
or you could find an opening book and I
I don't study this opening particularly
so I'm not sure in my mind if we put it
on C4 maybe we're kind of inviting black
one day to play D5 I know they just
played D6 but if my Bishop is out here
it does incentivize black to kind of get
back a free turn because I'm probably
going to have to at some point spend
time wasting a move by getting this
bishop somewhere else
so maybe that's why I go here and
probably you don't go to D3 because you
don't want to undefend this Knight right
notice the queen online with that Knight
so you know we can maybe try and work
those out but if you don't see them
again the opening isn't where I would
focus your energy when you're trying to
learn from a master game
Bishop td7 preparing the castle and both
sides Castle
and at this point we're not really out
of the opening we have one or two more
moves where the pieces get developed but
once you have a good sense of where all
of the minor pieces are going to be and
where the kings are going to be located
I feel like that's probably when we have
entered the middle game
it's at least a very good indication
we're in that direction
so now when we're in a middle game you
want to look at a few uh different
things right the reason the center
is so important in the opening is
because it's a great launching point for
no matter where your opponent decides to
play if they're making a big Queen set
attack or if they're castling kingside
and fortifying whatever they do it gives
us time to kind of react and respond
accordingly because you can imagine it's
going to be a lot easier right say that
my knight is here in the center if I
decide I want to fight on the king side
it's going to be easier for me to
relocate this Knight in this direction
than it is if this Knight's all the way
on this Edge
right I could pile up all my pieces over
here and hope my opponent goes on the
king side and then maybe they Castle
Queen side or maybe that's just not a
good area for me to attack and I've
wasted a lot of time so putting stuff in
the center makes it a great launching
point for both sides of the board gives
me some options
once we're in the middle game the center
is still usually important because it's
still a launching point and you want to
be able to have lots of Versatility with
your pieces but we also now have a sense
of some of the key areas to attack once
you're in the middle game you want to
start looking for weaknesses
the king is kind of always a Sami
weakness because it's the most important
piece so if you have opportunities to
attack the king it's a great place to
start and if you look at a position and
just have no clue what you're supposed
to be doing looking at where your
opponent's king is placed usually is a
good indication of what you can start to
do
some of the other things you can look
out for are where your pieces are placed
where you have more control so the pawns
right if you have a pawn chain
sometimes that can suggest a direction
to fight because you have more control
in that direction of the board or if you
have more pieces like I'm noticing that
these Bishops are pretty versatile
they're kind of attacking on both sides
and so I get to make a decision of maybe
where I want to orient them
so some of these things are for your
consideration and you can always look at
you know weaknesses like double pawns or
unprotected pieces anything that you
think might give you a tactical
Advantage is a fair place to try and
attack
so let's see in this position there's
not any clear I think tactical threats
so let's start to look at more carefully
what happens
four is the move played by white and I
think this is a really interesting move
because notice
whenever you have two Pawns in the
center
and even though you know it's not the
actual Center like D4 but it's still
towards the center of the board
notice how much control these pawns
actually exert because they look kind of
you know normal just when you look at
two pawns next to each other and then
you realize oh they control all of this
space that's four squares right that's
basically half of the board
in one row you can say the same thing
with fees right they're more defensively
oriented but it's still a lot of control
that these pawns are exerting
so there's a value to having space in
that way
um
we also notice that if we think back on
what happened in this game White made uh
some pushes with this Pawn eventually
right they pushed F5 and F6 broke
through Black's Castle they brought
their Queen over this way their Rook
slid up and over
um
and so we can see already from move nine
white is planting the seeds that are
going to let them eventually break
through with this attack so white I
think had the same assessment we did
that there's not any clear weaknesses in
this position so building towards an
eventual plan to go for the king is
going to pay off in the long run
black plays Queen to C7
and again I think this move generally
makes sense they're controlling or
fighting for control of E5 because you
don't want to give your opponent just a
huge foothold in the center it's also
putting the queen on this semi-open file
that didn't become majorly relevant
later but it was something noteworthy
right this piece once these nights kind
of clear out of the way
the Queen's going to have a lot more
control on this Avenue of the board
uh and it's also whenever you move the
queen out we don't like to move the
queen out too early right
um because if you move her out before a
lot of these other pieces are developed
there's a much better chance that they
can bring those pieces out with plans to
attack right and the Queen's gonna have
to run around all over trying to avoid
these trades and your opponent is going
to get time to set up all their pieces
once you see where the pieces are set up
right once we're in a middle game and
most of the pieces are decided and you
see where the kings are placed you
usually have a much better sense of how
to pick a spot safely with the queen so
there are ways that white could maybe
try to attack this queen you know maybe
bringing a knight over
but black has accounted for those and is
not worried that in that black is
probably thinking these are going to be
overextending
Queen to E1
again the benefit of hindsight in this
game is we know what ultimately happens
the queen is going to jump out to H4 and
put a ton of pressure on both H7 and on
F6
so just keeping in mind just this one
subtle little move and how versatile
that was to help with the attack
something again there's you can kind of
try and do some deep analysis and then
come back at the end and think okay what
are the major things I looked up you can
also just as you're going through
try and think of stuff you can take and
apply to your own game for me something
like this is once you develop your
pieces we can already start to say how
can I
find whatever I'm fighting for whether
it's directly going for the king for an
attack or picking up some other weakness
but how can I start to slowly maneuver
my pieces to make that option more
available depending on what happens so
this move is not committing immediately
to a major attack on the king side but
it's putting white in a much better
position to execute an attack on the
king side if that becomes an available
or enticing opportunity
okay Black's next move was to trade here
on D4
and I put a little kind of dubious
notation this question exclaim meaning
this isn't necessarily a mistake but it
is maybe not the best might be a little
inaccurate
and let's think about why this might be
well my thought is
this night is not real like the fact
that it's fighting for control and
putting pressure on the center is
valuable
giving that up we want to get something
for it what is black getting well
they've opened up this line for their
Queen which could be a little relevant
they've maybe opened up just this square
like if they ever wanted to move the
bishop here might take a little bit of
time but that's a possibility but really
I think the downside
is it invites white to get a massive
control in the center right this bishop
now is a monster and Black's plan for
this was to play E5 and shut this bishop
down and win some time
and white thin retreats
black maybe wanted white to take here
um I think this would have
worked out a lot better for black this
is probably what they were thinking is
something like takes
and if white you know goes for some like
kind of there's some really interesting
ideas something like Queen to G3 here
which looks like it gives up the bishop
but we want to be really careful about
our pins so our Queen is now lined up
with our opponents and if they take we
can take back and we're putting the
queen online with a king so maybe black
thought oh well white might want to go
for this idea and black has a really
solid answer with a counter pin
of Bishop to C5
now you can't take this Pawn you can't
take it with the bishop it's not legal
if you take with the queen
well uh oh you still can't take it back
so you don't want to oops you don't want
to lose your queen
let's get back to where we were
and to me this looks like a really
Pleasant position
for black to have something like this
where black is basically equalized the
center is really well controlled
um and I mean it's still a fight but I
think black feels very good here
considering how they were a little more
passive before so being able to maybe
facilitate something like this in my
mind this is what black was thinking
they were thinking we're going to trade
these Knights
and when the bishop comes out we can
gain time on it if they try and trade
we're good and if they back off well
we're also fine
we have launched a pawn into the center
and I have I I think this is kind of
another key moment in this game
because
what Black's plan here is just a little
bit flawed and the way white punishes
black for this mistaken plane is just
really brilliant and very subtle
um we looked at some of the moments
later in the game with like Queen H4 and
these like pins and Checkmate ideas and
they're really kind of fancy and pretty
and helpful for tactical thinking
but I think this moment
Knight takes D4 into E5 and then these
following two Bishop moves Bishop to E6
and Bishop to C4 are actually
the only major mistakes black makes this
whole game and I think they're the
reason black loses
so I want to take some time with these
so what's really interesting
is blacks thinking we have gained a
foothold in the center and now there's a
chance now that this Pawn is not on E6
right the whole purpose is we're going
to develop this bishop where are we
going to put it well they didn't just
want to put it here
you can't put it anywhere over here
because white controls all these squares
so really the whole purpose of this
maneuver
besides trying to gain control in the
center
is to open up E6 for the bishop
Black's plan here I think was
anticipating okay well if they push F5
then maybe they have a little more
control on the king side but I have
better control in the center right this
Pawn is a lot harder to contest now that
White's pushed past and decided not to
exchange and black thinks okay well we
can just trade these pieces and this is
fine
but there's a few problems I think
probably black should have just played
for some quiet development
there's a little bit of tempo wasted
right this piece moves twice just to be
captured once so maybe a little bit of
tempo and I think the biggest problem is
looking at the color complexes this is
not something that is always immediately
noticeable when you look at the board
but if I'm looking at this position
let's look uh let's I'm going to switch
it actually to Black's perspective it's
a good Black's perspective
which squares do we have better control
of as the black Army here and if you're
in the audience or in the chat feel free
to leave some thoughts but what do you
think do you think we have a better
control over the dark squares or the
light squares as the black Army here
foreign
a few conflicting thoughts in the chat
when I look at this position
I think that black is
not dominating but pretty well
controlling the dark squares
I see this bishop is kind of around
holding everything together on the
defense this queen is lined up with this
Pawn chain all of which controls dark
squares
right the bishop through it the queen
now black control some light squares
right this Knight controls a few
this bishop controls a few but it's not
really developed I think black controls
the dark square is much better
so it is an interesting decision
when you control one set of squares and
not the other
to immediately trade away the piece that
helps you control your weak points
right if we flip this back
's decision
is okay I'm gonna bring the bishop out
White NOW gets a foothold on the light
squares
right the Knight the pawns so Black's
fighting on the light or the dark
squares and whites fighting on the light
squares
and black decides to give up their light
squared Bishop right a real major
Contender for those squares and it's now
even though black has a foothold in the
center there I think are two problems
one
there's this problem of okay
White's already lining up to start
fighting on your king side and now
you're just giving them a foothold in
that territory
and the second problem relates to this
Pawn
on D6
this Pawn is uh what we would call a
backwards Pawn what that means is there
are no pawns beside or behind it that
can help support its motion forward
so these two pawns are connected right
you could move either one of them up and
the other one would guard it so they're
just connected pawns this is still
connected right it's not isolated it's
not on its own it's connected to one but
it's only on the defensive side because
anytime it moves forward it has to move
through enemy territory and it doesn't
have the defense of an extra Pawn
this means it's especially hard to move
forward and the square in front of a
backwards Pawn is really weak because uh
if there were pawns next to it they
could help cover the square in front of
it either by moving forward or just by
being there
but because there are none on either
side that are behind it this square is
really weak
it's also easier to attack so it's
harder to defend and it's harder to move
forward so backwards pawns are a bit of
a weakness that we can try and exploit
as white and white does this in a really
beautiful way not by trying to win this
Pawn but by trying to gain control of
the light squares in a basically
uncontestable way
black did the hard part of trading off
this light squared Bishop right with
that around it's even though we can have
better control black still is going to
have a piece that's able to fight and
kind of keep us off right even if at
this point black decides just to back
off
it's a lot harder for us to you know
make really strong progress in this
position because we have better control
of the light squares but anytime we try
and invade they have this piece that
they can use to try and repel us
once this piece is gone
we have the opportunity to invade in a
way that black just can't deal with and
so we know that there's this kind of
nice Square
uh yeah so someone on the Trap pointing
out we also have a backwards Pawn
um on e4 that's true and Black's plan
here we notice they try and attack it
but the reason I think this one is more
important is because there's the
semi-open file
so ours is stuck behind a pawn it's not
moving anyway so as long as we can keep
it safe we're good
but this Pawn actually would like to
move forward
and we can deny that and put pressure on
it but white actually again goes a
different way not just in the attacking
means
but white decides to take advantage of
this Square
because black has no light squared
Bishop
and because there are no pawns able to
defend the square
if we can get a piece placed on this
Square it's going to dominate and as we
already saw from this game this piece
that eventually ends up here is this
night
and we get an outpost where the Knight
is placed on this beautiful square and
controls so much of the board that it's
very very hard to contest
the question is how do we do that well
it's very simple
we have to get rid of the pieces that
can take it
in this case I mean the queen can always
take but you're never trading a queen
for a night or something so we don't
have to worry about that and a rook
sometimes will take but that's always
them giving up an exchange the only
piece we really care about here are the
pieces of equal or lesser value well we
know the pawns can't do it there aren't
any there
the bishop can't do it it's on the wrong
color they needed a light squared bishop
and they traded it away so this Knight
is the only piece in our way
and so white very quickly and
efficiently finds a move that deals with
both problems the problem of this Pawn
we move the bishop so it's defended
and the point is we're not just trying
to defend we actually just want to take
this Knight
it's a really kind of uh fascinating
thing it's just so simple but once we
get rid of this piece
our nitrous comes in and we're doing
really well
black plays Rook to E8 the problem if if
they try and I mean black just can't
afford to not trade this piece right if
they move it well this bishop isn't
defended by anything so we're just going
to win that piece so black tries as
quickly as they can to get out of this
problem right now The Bishop's defended
now their next move they're probably
going to run away if they get the chance
but white doesn't give them that chance
we take
Bishop takes back uh you could take with
the pawn but again if Black's trying to
keep their King safe we don't want to
open up this attack we already know
white wants to do that and also this is
maybe the worst Bishop I've ever seen in
my whole life oh it's I would call this
piece a tall Pawn because unfortunately
it's just not doing anything so yeah you
probably have to take with the bishop
and
now white has this opportunity to jump
in and it might not have been obvious in
the game because it didn't last super
long the Knight jumps into D5 and then
makes uh eventually traded off for this
bishop uh and I think it turned out for
this turned off for something over here
um
and kind of ruined Black's Pawn
structure and white was able to carry
out the checkmating attack
but if we spend some more time and look
at this piece we can realize just how
devastating it is
so this Knight is
really kind of one it's occupying a
square that can't be contested we know
that it's also just denying anything
this bishop could ever hope or dream
because it controls virtually every
Square the bishop does right the bishop
gets two extras this one and this one
our Queen controls here
so our Knight is basically just
dominating this bishop and in doing so
it's also cutting off the Rooks right
they're not connected to each other
anymore if you don't put this bishop
back here then black also has to be
afraid of possible night Forks right
this looks really juicy so you have to
be careful of that
um and they also have to be careful of
eventually you know the Knight coming
into F6 and messing with the King if
that's ever an opportunity so this
bishop is just so overworked this Knight
is really putting in some overtime here
and there's also an interesting moment
where white black could try and take
this pawn and instead they chose to back
off with the bishop now maybe they
didn't want just a trade
and maybe you could make an argument for
that you know black has one upon but
their King is exposed but we have traded
off a lot of Firepower it's possible
even if black goes on hides in the
center we might just not have enough to
finish off this game
so yeah I'm not sure that that's fully
the reason
but actually if we take a closer look
this move is unplayable
it is white to move because this is a
variation I'll let you try and take a
stab at it but see if you can figure out
why Queen 2 uh C2 winning the pawn is
just not very good it has to do with our
beautifully placed Knight and how we can
take advantage of all of our threats but
how can we punish this queen
so a few people are on the right track
in the chat
um with the idea that okay we noticed
that the Knight wants to go to C7 and
get a fork and we have this idea of
playing Rook to C1 which attacks the
queen and defends that square now we
have to be a little bit careful here
because I think if we play Rook C1 right
away
there I think there's a slight problem
I want to try and remember
exactly why but then this I think this
might work but it might be a slight in
accuracy maybe it's just they take
enough material down with them that it's
not as good so the the more precise way
to start is with Rook to F2 because now
we're going to defend all of this and
the problem for black is there's
actually just no way to like avoid this
problem anyway
right because where can black safely
move
if you go to
say A4 well that's great now we don't
have Rook C1
but we don't need Rook C1 anymore
because the Queen's not defending the
square so we can just get the fork so
the queen has to stay on this line and
you know wherever it goes Rook C1 is
still following and we can still follow
with this idea so
you had the right idea uh with this yeah
this black is just too exposed here so
even though that threat never came up in
the game
it's something that where we can plug it
into a computer or you know have like
someone do some analysis or commentary
on it and try and figure that out we can
see that this Knight is applying tons of
implicit pressure even when it doesn't
actually come up in the game
so the bishop goes back to d8
and white plays a really subtle move and
something so nice about this game is
notice that there's I don't think
there's any sense of urgency from the
white player from this point on maybe in
the end with a few tactical ideas but it
feels like white is just kind of taking
it slow and steady because black has no
threats
all of Black's pieces are kind of tied
down defending important squares the
only piece that's really free to run
around is the queen
and she just doesn't have anywhere good
at Target
so white can just really slowly
consolidate their position make sure
that there's no weaknesses in their
defense and then press on for a victory
right black tries to make something
happen by pushing forward on the queen
side
B3 very simple just attacking the queen
keeping everything safe check doesn't
really matter we have plenty of time so
the king steps off to the side
Rook to C8 again just trying to make
something happen here
but with this Knight there's just never
really any threat I mean maybe you can
try and activate the bishop get some
more pressure
and white just kind of denies this with
Rook to F3
um in the chat somebody wanted Rook to
F3 we played earlier but again kind of
the nice thing is with this Knight just
so firmly planted all of Black's pieces
are being used for defense just trying
to keep everything safe and there's just
no need for us to feel any urgency
um
black here plays King to h8 and white
plays F6 this is kind of a harder moment
to find I think if you're playing on
your own but we can understand having
seen the game again White's point is
just let's devastate this Pawn structure
and to me something instructive about
this is to realize the point isn't to
make these doubled pawns right I think
some people might say oh well you've
made double pawns and you've opened up a
line
I think a big part of the point too
something nice about creating a gap in
your opponent's you know Castle
is that this Pawn now is very hard to
defend
before this move if we execute our idea
right we can't do it now because of the
bishop but like uh whatever give us five
moves or something if we execute our
idea of the queen and Rook on this line
you know maybe white can or maybe black
can just play H6 and hold for a while
because they have pawns defending so we
see very concretely one of the benefits
to breaking up the structure is the
pawns just don't defend each other as
well
so this is really nice something we
should do again when we're looking at a
game and we want to understand a 98 you
might say okay well black just kind of
made it easy on white right they they
took this pawn and everything falls
apart what if they play G6
why not just do this and now if you go
for your attacks maybe just like H5 and
you know the pawn still defend each
other it does not solve the problem
well let's take a look what uh what
might be wrong with this plan
how can white continue here to try and
yeah somebody already commenting there's
just way too many holes this position is
like swiss cheese there's just a massive
weakness on this square and it's almost
impossible to defend right this bishop
like if we're looking at which piece is
more uh effective in this position right
this bishop needs to control this dark
square and this dark Square because this
one is there's maybe a mate thread if we
can ever get our Queen over to G7
an E7 maybe we our Knight can get in
somehow and we can make lots of threats
so this bishop just and it can't do
anything it's totally tied down by this
Pawn
the king
we have uh locked down fully with our
Pawn so this is yeah really hard to
defend
um people are suggesting a few different
things some people want to sack a rook
uh which I think we might do in some
variations some people just want to push
h4h5 and start launching down H4 I don't
like as much because I think it is met
with H5
um and maybe it's a little harder for us
to invade
one there's there are a lot of ways to
win here right the nice thing is
everything is fortified on our side we
have no weaknesses it's just a matter of
time and applying the right pressure but
one line that I think looks really nice
is something like Queen to H4
the point is we're going to go to H6 and
to G7 with checkmate
if you try and start me with H5 I'm just
going to go to G5 and H6 anyway
and if you stop me again with King H7
now I can just sacrifice material maybe
I can play like G4 and just take stuff
you can just very simply play Rook H3
and there's a lot of pins in this
position right now
uh if black just does nothing our thread
is just to take because if you recapture
then Queen to G7 is checkmate
and if you don't recapture my Queens
coming in and winning the game
um so if you try and stop that with
something like Rook to G8
now if I take this is defended
well the problem is I can just take it
anyway
because now if you take your Rook has
covered your Escape Square
so it's checkmate
so Black's King is just kind of falling
apart no matter what they try and do G6
looks like it's solid uh it looks like
you're holding stuff together but we've
noticed that yeah there's just so much
room that plaque is now opened up for
holes and attacks in their position
that's not really tenable to try and
defend something like this even though
this looks really scary this was
actually the better option for black
probably to try and get some fighting
chances because even though it's harder
to defend this Pawn well at least maybe
we have an open file maybe there's some
counter-attacking possibilities if our
opponent makes a mistake
so that's I think a better fighting way
Queen to H4
and Rook goes to GA to play defense
there is another really interesting move
in this position that I think is worth
looking at and it's what if F5 is played
the point here
is the bishop attacks the queen
and we leave the question of okay well
why what are you doing because if you
give me enough time maybe my Bishop can
defend these dark squares and I can
still slide my rook in and survive
again there's a few different ways to
handle this position
and since the variation isn't like
critical uh I won't make you try and
guess it because there's a few other
points I want to kind of harp on
but I think one really nice move here is
still to play Knight to F6
normally we would want to just let the
Knight sit and enjoy what it's doing but
here there's actually a nice opportunity
because if you take and you have to
because my thread is Checkmate and
there's no move that stops that besides
the take I I guess you could sack your
queen but like there's no serious try
Queen takes with check and now we have a
nice forcing sequence the king's got to
go to G8
we can bring in our Rook with check more
attacks
the King goes to f8 only move
we can slide The Rook now down to G7
where it's threatening mate again
uh you have to defend this maybe you can
bring this Rook up but let's say
something like Rook t7
and white again there's lots of
different ways to try and win here but
something very very simple is to just
take the pawn
and your point is you're going to come
down with a back rank threat
black can try and run away
but eventually you're gonna run out
right in this position
we can get a nice skewer and forcibly
win the piece if you try and block this
doesn't work because now you're not
defending this Pawn
and eventually the king's just going to
fall we're going to get at least a rook
probably more and
the the point isn't necessarily the
variation but just kind of the idea that
we can cash in this really powerful
piece in order to get our pieces that
much closer to remove this critical
defender of the dark squares and once
this king is on the ropes and our pieces
are calling check and check and check
it's just very hard to get out of
so F5 doesn't work and that's something
you could explore if you thought well
wait a minute uh what if they played
that you can look with a computer and
try and find some of those ideas
Rook to G8 and now we saw again White's
really beautiful forcing idea of Knight
takes F6 very similar to what it was
before trying to force this this trade
eventually and just gain so much control
because once all these pieces are
locked up then White's going to have
free reign to finish the game
The Rook jumps up and if the bishop
takes then it's very similar right this
is going to end up with something really
similar to what we saw in the game
right and we can continue with these
kind of ideas
nothing really is going to change too
dramatically
so instead Rook G7 and Rook G3
right the threats are this still active
mate threat taking
uh just yeah a lot to deal with and
black eventually just kind of crumbled
under the pressure there wasn't really
anything too much to do
but the fact that we can exploit these
really nice pins that Black's King is
totally locked down and has no good ways
to escape
and uh the fact that yeah just all of
these threats were really masterfully
mined by white
and what's so funny here is with Rook to
D1 we notice that everything now kind of
comes full circle and this backwards
Pawn is now the final uh way that we can
break through all right we take the pawn
there's not a good way to defend it and
then the Rook comes through to the end
uh in the chat you're also saying yeah
you can just kind of run the pawn down
um
yeah this might work maybe like H5 or
something in Black I'm not sure but
there's a lot of winning ideas here
so when we have looked at a game like
this
maybe the only other line we're saying
is yeah like this also wins white
decided to take this first but you could
also take on D5 here the only downside
is now the queen can back up and it's a
little harder to break through this
Fortress you can still do it right Rook
takes Queen takes Queen takes
we can break through enough to get some
Advantage but we've turned basically a
checkmating attack into we have some
extra pawns we're gonna win in an end
game
so you can try that
but I like the way white played it of
removing the critical Defenders first
okay but back to our original question
which was what can we learn from this
game
I think there's a few things to keep in
mind and again the it's not just from
this game but really I want you to take
the lesson of what can you how can you
approach a master game and learn
something from it and apply it to your
own game right we've talked about a lot
of ideas with this game in this one we
talked about
fighting for the opening right how to
control the center how to you know
leverage your uh control especially the
color complexes I think that becomes
important as we move into the middle
game
we looked at the value of controlling
lots of space with the pawns right why
it's so important to try and have your
pawns move forward and work together
we looked at the value of kind of more
subtle moves like lining up the queen to
eventually attack on the king side and
how to make a plan for which side of the
board to attack
and then we talked about why Black's
plan here wasn't so good
we said their plan of you know getting
some Tempo trying to gain control in the
center
was effective only if white decided to
capture
so this is another important thing that
I think beginners can really learn from
a lot is sometimes you get kind of in
like a tunnel vision of a variation and
you say oh well if I do this they do
this I do this out of this and you're
looking at very forcing moves sometimes
it's okay to think well what if they
just Retreat what if they don't take
what if they step out of check
and thinking of some of those more
simple options sometimes they're also
effective and this is something that
even Grand Masters as we can see fell
into now in this case I'm sure that uh
rutakovsky here planned for what White's
going to do but his plan involved
getting this bishop into the game
he didn't like that this piece wasn't
developed he wanted it out of the way to
make room for the rook and so he thought
well let's just trade it off won't have
to deal with it and that's okay too
maybe the lesson with the piece the
mistake here and the the value of pieces
is to look at which pieces and which
colors do you control which piece which
color complexes do your pieces control
um and how can you you know use some for
offense and some for defense and balance
that out which ones can you afford to
get rid of
and then we spent a good amount of time
as well looking at this Outpost right
this whole weakness this backwards Pawn
that is created when white refused to
take back is now the long-term weakness
that basically costs black the game
because white can slowly but surely
trade away everything that controls the
square plays a really valuable Knight on
it and cash that night in when the
moment is right but until then just put
lots of pressure on the position
and in the very end eventually swing
this Rook over and use it to break
through and be the final kind of winning
touch
so thinking about I think an outpost is
like especially useful thing about how
you can make your nights really valuable
is and we can imagine right after Rook
to E8 I think a very normal move in like
a in a beginner intermediate game would
be just to immediately place the knight
in the center put a lot of pressure here
this unfortunately loses because after
Knight takes D5 you think oh well I'm
attacking everything I'm gonna get
something back but if you take the
bishop the Knight gets out of Harm's Way
and somehow black has done a magic trick
where they take two of your pieces for
one of theirs
and the same thing happens if you take
the Knight
so it's very easy to get a little antsy
with your plans but just taking time and
for planning to say what is the obstacle
what's in my way
how can I get rid of it and how can I
you know execute this how can my
opponent stop it and just taking a
little more time with it
and finally once white was in this
winning position I think it was also
really critical that white didn't just
you know blow it away make some crazy
sacrifice and try and win too
aggressively white fortified their
defenses saw what was the weaknesses in
their position how can I resolve that
and then slowly but surely improve their
position into a win so no need to rush
when you are doing well when you're
winning in a position take your time
don't just you know throw it away
these are the kinds of lessons that I
think we can learn from Master games and
the the lessons are going to vary from
game to game what's important what
sticks out but I think this process if
you've never done it before feel free to
try it with some other games other
Master games ones you've looked at
before once you haven't once you've
heard of
look through the game go through it all
the way try and figure out the basic
idea of okay what's the point of these
moves but don't go super in depth once
you've seen it once you understand okay
here's what happened here's how it
played out go back through take a little
more time maybe work on it with a friend
use a computer and try and understand
okay what really happened why did one of
these Masters win or lose
where do I think they went wrong where
does the computer think they went wrong
and what can I take from that to apply
to my game it doesn't have to be
profound doesn't have to be a lot right
I've given us a lot of options to think
about for lessons but my recommendation
for you would be to pick one right
what's the one thing that you can take
and apply to your chest so maybe for me
it's I really want to look at these
outposts and say if I have a chance
where I see a backwards pawn and I have
a knight that could land there how can I
get rid of the opponent's pieces that
could be mine you can pick something
else that's totally up to you but
finding just one thing you can take from
a game look at how the GM did it and
trying to ask yourself how can I do that
in my games I think it'll help you and
hopefully this lesson has helped you
feel more comfortable at learning with
the Masters my name's uh Ben Alex
mullering it's been awesome to work with
you today hopefully you stick around
because right up next we're going to
have our grand master Benjamin Bach here
to do grandmaster's choice so please
stick around for that thank you for
listening and have a great night
foreign
[Music]